[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres
nous recevons laurent mazaury adjoint au
maire d'elancourt en charge de la
culture
nous ferons un point sur la saison
culturelle dans la ville notamment au
prisme et à la ferme du mousseau et puis
nous avons interviewé david lappartient
le président de la fédération française
de cyclisme
nous l'avons rencontré lors d'une
cérémonie organisée vendredi dernier au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ou plusieurs élus saint quentinois ont
été récompensés d'une médaille d'or
nous débutons ce 7,8 les invités avec
laurent mazaury adjoint au maire
d'elancourt en charge de la culture
avec lui nous reviendrons sur la saison
culturelle à la ferme du mousseau mais
aussi au prisme
bonsoir monsieur mazaury bonsoir merci
de m'accueillir bah merci d'être sur ce
plateau
alors dites nous tout qu'est ce qui va
qu'est ce que c'est quoi la suite à la
ferme du mousseau alors la suite c'est
une renaissance c'est un niveau nouveau
puisque après pratiquement deux ans
darren programmation de la saison
culturelle nous relançons une saison
culturelle à la ferme du mousseau
alors à quoi peut-on s'attendre alors à
beaucoup de choses tout d'abord il faut
insister sur le fait que nous avons
harmonisé notre programmation avec celle
du prisme dans l'idée d'une
programmation à la fois éclectique qui
répondent donc à la tante de tous les
publics mais également avec une
programmation qui fasse sens pour
l'ensemble de ce que nous allons
présenter
nous avons essentiellement travaillé à
la ferme du mousseau en complémentarité
avec la programmation du prisme et nous
allons donc orienter cette année notre
programme essentiellement vers le jeune
public
alors qu'est ce que ça donne en plus le
prisme et la ferme du mousseau a
beaucoup de choses ça ouvre des champs
de possibles extraordinaire d'abord nous
travaillons depuis plus de 30 ans a
encore à la scion avec le prisme et
pendant très longtemps nous avons
programmé nos saisons de manière
concertée et nous ne sommes également
échangé beaucoup de programmes avec le
prisme est également avec l'ensemble des
scènes de saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
a donc cette année renforcer ce
partenariat en laissant au prisme tout
ce qui touche à la danse au prisme ce
qui touche à dire au grand public mais
en ce qui concerne la typologie de la
programmation orientée vers le plus
grand nombre et nous à la ferme
en complément nous allons orienter notre
programmation vert
le jeune public la petite enfance
également et verges avec une progression
beaucoup plus familial on va s'atteler
un petit peu sur la ferme du mousseau
dites moi alors le jeune public qu'est
ce qui va découvrir c'est un lieu
familial est à vous qu'est ce qui nous
attend alors ces sentiments du théâtre
d'abord vous avez une primeur
extraordinaire puisque même les élans
courtois ne l'ont pas encore eu dans
leur boîte aux lettres nous avons je
vous présente ici le programme de la
nouveau programme de la saison
culturelle à la ferme du mousseau que je
vous offre un grand plaisir à remercier
je veux le montrer aussi que l'ensemble
donc des habitants pourront découvrir
encartés avec leur bulletin municipal du
mois de février
la distribution est en cours et donc
vous avez l'ensemble des quatorze
programmes qui vous sont proposés donc
je ne vais pas en faire ici l'article
l'idée c'est que les gens puissent le le
lire vous pouvez bien entendu le
découvrir aussi sur le site internet de
la ville
l'orientation et les petite enfance elle
est bien entendu également public jeune
et il est lé familiale on y retrouve des
comptes on y retrouve le mélange entre
la musique et le théâtre
on y retrouve un petit peu de danse on y
retrouve aussi on y tenait parti dans
cette année y compris des programmes qui
ont lieu au prisme comme c'est le cas
par exemple pour les brames pop rock on
sont créés par cette fois ci notre école
de musique d'elancourt tout ça vers une
orientation qui soit encore une fois
tout public ce sur quoi j'ai ainsi c'est
que la culture à l encours comme
ailleurs d'ailleurs ce doit être à la
fois grandir son âme mais c'est
également y prendre du plaisir je pense
qu'on a trop longtemps oublié que l'on
peut se cultiver en prenant du plaisir
une façon de prendre du plaisir c'est
aussi d'orienter et de l'ouvrir à tous
les publics et de ne pas être seulement
dans une culture qu'ils soient trop
élitiste j'allais dire une culture
qu'ils soient trop parisienne dans nos
territoires
il faut qu'on ait un accès facile à la
culture et qu'on nous ressorte en ayant
eu du bonheur c'est le but entre autres
de la ferme du mousseau en
complémentarité avec le prix c'est
d'avoir une programmation qui donnent de
la joie au plus grand nombre
et si je comprends bien il ya des
personnes de la ville qui contribue
comme les écoles de musique qui
participent à ce côté culture c'est
c'est important pour vous tout à fait
c'est essentiel c'est d'autant plus
essentielle à ferme du mousseau où nous
avons fait ce que nous appelons une
délégation de service public nous avons
donc mis au point un partenariat avec
une troupe qui s'appelle le théâtre de
chair qui programme avec nous et qui
gère le lieu vraiment en concertation en
corrélation 7e et nous qui ont travaillé
ensemble sur cette programmation en
relation avec le prisme et ses deux
théâtres de chair qui assure cette
prestation
d'accueil des troupes en résidence
d'osmose de la programmation de
prestations de services pour ses troupes
pour que la lumière soit parfaite que le
son soit bonne qualité que l'accueil des
habitants soit au top et ça on le doit à
la corrélation est au travail entre
notre personnel municipal et la troupe
du théâtre de chair qui est elle même
d'ailleurs une troupe de théâtre qui
produit qui crée énormément théâtre
entre autres avec le théâtre très à
paris vous voyez qu'on est vraiment dans
cette idée là d'offrir au plus grand
nombre un accès au théâtre et au
spectacle vivant dans un lieu convivial
mais j'insiste encore une fois ce
travail de complémentarité avec le prix
ce qui est essentiel pour nous pour
répondre à la tante de l'ensemble des
habitants des encours toi et j'allais
dire plus généralement des habitants de
50 ans divine quand on parle du prisme
mais ils sont également bien sûr les
bienvenues aussi à la ferme
alors on va passer un petit peu et très
rapidement sur le prises qu'on a parlé
de la ferme du mousseau alors le prisme
qu'est ce que ça va donner cette suite
de saison aussi c'est de la danse c'est
pour tout le monde c'est alors le prisme
c'est d'abord effectivement vous avez
raison ça a toujours été sur une
orientation historique le lieu ouvert à
la danse la pratique de la danse
d'ouverture de la danse au plus grand
nombre
donc le prisme à une programmation de
deuxième partie de saison puisque nous
sommes déjà dans la deuxième saison ça
va très très vite a déjà une
programmation qui demeurent orientés
vers la danse
ensuite c'est un petit peu nouveau cette
année le prisme en plus des spectacles
de qualité qu'il donne au niveau musical
le niveau one man show a également
programmé à son nombre de pièces de
théâtre beaucoup plus grand public
c'est un travail en commun qu'on a fait
avec eux là tu d'ailleurs je voudrais
couper court à toute polémique a pu
avoir c'est un vrai travail en commun
qui a été fait que sa directrice qui
d'ailleurs bientôt partir à la retraite
je vous invite pour la saluer ici sabine
que ça ce travail nous permet
effectivement d'offrir au plus grand
nombre en accès à un théâtre plus
populaire mais le populaire c'est pas un
gros mot c'est quelque chose qui nous
semblent positifs on se cultive en et en
faisant du théâtre populaire et donc le
prisme cette année va sur l'année a fait
la fin de la saison 2017 et j'espère sur
la saison 2010 8 nous offrir une
programmation qui sera encore plus
éclectique et plus ouverte que par le
passé et bien je vous remercie monsieur
mazaury en tout cas vous nous avez donné
envie d'aller à la ferme du mousseau et
au prisme et on va découvrir la
péjoration que je prends a oui ça c'est
vous et que je montre à découvrir sur
internet et puis vont tous nous recevoir
incessamment sous peu
exactement merci à vous monsieur mazaury
bonne soirée merci de votre accueil un
mot de ce sport après
la fédération française de cyclisme a
organisé vendredi dernier une cérémonie
au vélodrome nationale objectif rendre
hommage aux acteurs politiques saint
quentinois qui ont oeuvré pour la
construction de la structure
michel laugier président de saint
quentin en yvelines ainsi que son
prédécesseur robert cadalbert et
l'ancien vice président yves macheboeuf
ont reçu la médaille d'or des mains du
président de la ffc david lappartient
nous l'avons interviewé alors je suis
avec david lappartient qui est encore
pour quelques jours président de l'afer
lasson française de cyclisme on est au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
et justement c'est par rapport à cette
structure que nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui car aujourd'hui on honorait
les personnes qui ont travaillé pour la
construction de ce magnifique vélodrome
qui est derrière nous oui c'est vrai que
je voulais profiter de ces derniers
jours puisque c'est le 11 mars prochain
que je quitterai la présence de la
fédération pour honorer michel laugier
robert cadalbert et images boeuf qui ont
vraiment porté du début à la fin ce
dossier de vélodrome nationale on a eu
la chance d'avoir ces élus et qui ont su
convaincre tous leurs collègues de
l'agglomération et je ne pouvais pas ne
pas au nom de la fédération les
remercier pour tout ce travail et c'est
pour ça que j'ai souhaité le faire
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que ça symbolise cette
médaille d'or pour le cyclisme alors la
médaille d'or de la fédération est une
médaille qu'on remet peu puisqu'il en
est autorisée on va dire que cinq
parents remise exclusivement par le par
le présent de la fédération pour des
dirigeants généralement émérite qui ont
donné quasiment leur vie au cyclisme
mais là on a fait une petite entorse à
la règle parce que
considéré au niveau de la fédération et
je considérais particulièrement en tant
que président que ce qui a été fait par
les élus pour créer ce vélodrome
nationale et bien s'est dotée la
fédération d'un toit s'est lui donné de
perspectives pour le siècle à venir et
rien que pour ça cet engagement méritait
d'être souligné et d'être récompensé par
la médaille d'or de la fédération et je
crois que ça a été unanimement aussi
salué par tous mes collègues élus de la
fédération
quand on sait ce qu'on doit aux élus de
saint quentin pour cet investissement
ce vélodrome il a été dur à sortir de
terre vraiment dur il n'aime pas il n'a
pas été simple parce que vous savez une
aventure comme ça c'est une aventure
humaine ses 8 ans 8 ans de travail en
commun j'étais à l'époque premier vice
président vice président délégué de la
fédération française de cyclisme
j'ai déjà porté ce dossier puis ensuite
en tant que président il ya eu des
problèmes juridiques des problèmes
financiers
un moment l'équation n'était pas c'est à
dire qu'on n'arrivait pas au coût global
donc il a fallu trouver des rallonges et
voilà on a réussi par une vraie volonté
d'y arriver de tous les acteurs de
l'agglomération de l'état de la région
du département
tous ensemble on a réussi à trouver les
solutions pour y arriver il y avait
également vous en avait parlé il ya
quelques instants une anecdote sur
bernard laporte est ce que vous pouvez
nous la raconter alors avec bernard
laporte ça fournit mis ça fourmille
d'anecdotes mais on a eu effectivement
rencontre avec bernard laporte avec
robert cadalbert michel laugier images
boeuf est d'abord ce qui est assez
inhabituel c'est que il connaissait pas
encore les élus de saint quentin moi et
me connaissait et le tutoiement était
tout de suite de rigueur donc c'est
assez étonnant venant de la part d'un
ministre est tout de suite les trois
millions d'euros' a pu être bon et il a
dit mais en se retournant vers robert
cadalbert possible ni mines et voilà on
voyait pas trop des buts quoi elle
parlait en fait c'était le naming
effectivement il y avait une quelques
lettres qui avait été mangée de là
dedans et c'était le naming en fait du
bâtiment il l'a répété trois quatre fois
avant de nous montrer ce que c'était que
le naming et on savait ce que c'était
mon avait mal compris la phrase
donc c'est une petite anecdote assez
sympathique mais bernard laporte a été
très rapide pour dire oui la france a
besoin de ce vélodrome et on est reparti
de la réunion avec le soutien de trois
millions d'euros supplémentaires de
l'état
donc merci à verdun la porter à l'état
aussi pour cet investissement jusqu'à
nous il y à des cyclistes qui s'entraîne
c'est là la réussite du vélodrome des
cyclistes amateurs professionnels qui
s'entraînent ici tous les jours
alors c'est effectivement ça là le
succès c'est que ce vélodrome heavy nous
sommes ici entre midi et deux ça roule
vous revenez dans deux heures ça va des
équipes de france qui sont là vous
revenez soir ce sont les clubs c'est çà
çà çà çà vie sans arrêt ça roule sans
arrêt c'est ce qu'on voulait et c'est
une vraie réussite dans leurs questions
ou vos personnellement comment profiter
vous de ces derniers jours à la tête de
la fédération française de cyclisme
alors j'ai encore plein de choses à
faire donc on a un amant un conseil
fédéral aujourd'hui qui réunit quel
parlement de la fédération et j'ai
beaucoup de dossiers encore à terminer
la préparation de l'assemblée générale
de la fédération
et puis j'essaie aussi de présenter mon
successeur et il ya un seul candidat
aussi aux différents acteurs pour que la
transition se passe de la meilleure des
manières je pense que c'est aussi
important et
voilà pour l'instant je réalise pas trop
je pense qu'on aura sans doute un peu
d'émotion le 11 au soir le 11 mars
lorsque je quitterai définitivement
cette présidence de la fédération
quel bilan tirez vous de votre
présidence alors forcément on essaie de
tirer des bilans assez positive même si
j'ai pas forcément tout réussi mais déjà
la livraison de ce vélodrome nationale
je pense aussi avoir été au sein de la
fédération un des acteurs clefs majeures
pour que ce dossier sorte que les
poussées je les portais aussi à bout de
bras au niveau de la fédération
donc s'il y avait déjà une chose à
retenir à mon avis c'est celle là c'est
là la réforme complète aussi de la
gouvernance de la fédération de
gouvernance modernes un fonctionnement
moderne et puis c'est aussi le
développement c'est quand même 15 % de
licenciés en plus aux courtes et 7 c 7
ans et hausse continue de licencier
donc voilà le patrimoine cycliste
français qui a été qu'ils étaient
préservés donc c'est comme un bilan
plutôt positif même si j'aurais aimé
plus de médailles aux jeux olympiques et
particulièrement lors des jeux de rio
qui n'ont pas été à la hauteur de ce
qu'on espérait merci beaucoup david
lappartient
merci beaucoup merci c'est la fin de ce
set 8 des invités bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]